the air connection and for honor
definitely needs to be fixed and I think
all of us can agree that we've all at
least experienced this one or two times
whether that was you were mid-match and
the game froze on you because someone
left or the connection was bad which has
happened numerous times to me or when
you're just trying to find a game in the
game will give it to you because either
the server is full or you can connect to
that server whatsoever now this isn't
your problem although it could be but
most of people's not types seem to be
very strict and it's kind of confusing
why a majority of the player base is a
strict nat type but you can connect the
game's kind of okay and yet here's me
with a perfectly good map type and i'm
trying to get this and i get
disconnected from most every game it's
because you be sought as these things
called peer-to-peer servers now this is
a silicon beating a dead horse here
you're all going to you here you
probably heard this at least eight times
not even probably more but for the
people that don't understand what a
peer-to-peer server it is basically it's
take everyone in your dominion game you
have eight people all eight of you are
one out of the eight of you one of them
is a host that hosts are all do that
host you know is the host the other
seven have to feed off to his connection
so if the host leaves that causes the
mid you know Midway kind of freezing the
game person leaves and then continues or
just disconnects the server entirely
I've even at instances where a friend
just completely lagged out for
absolutely no reason mid-match and it's
very annoying to quit the game and then
come back and pick them up for it just
to happen the next time another thing
that's going to go or another thing that
they need to change is too like I said
get rid of these peer-to-peer servers
and get them to dedicated a fighting
game needs to be with dedicated servers
dedicated servers are basically ubisoft
is the host and all eight players
instead of just the seven are feeding
off of it so if you be soft servers go
to
[ __ ] at their company then that's when
we start lagging and this stuff this
stuff starts happening if they don't
then we're perfectly fine and we never
have to see these connection errors
again it's just a really big problem
that needs to be fixed I can understand
if this was the alpha or the beta but
the the Alpha was out I don't know month
or two ago maybe even longer I was never
in that beta I was never in the Alpha I
was in the closed beta it was still
happening as in the open beta it was
still happening and now we're in the
full game and it's happening even more
than it did in the open beta you would
think that Ubisoft would say hey there's
a problem going on with our game that's
been happening for all three times you
know all three times of this game has
been out here we could probably fix it
if they didn't want to fix the error if
they didn't want to fix anything with
the game why make the game just that's
just my quick little will call a rant
I'm just really up just upset that
Ubisoft is practically killing their own
game right now with all these problems
that's going on there's another problem
that needs to be addressed that I will
gladly talk about an longer detail in a
other video you'll understand that but I
hope you guys did enjoy this very quick
video just a couple minutes or so of
just me talking about some I hope you
all did it I hope you all did enjoy like
the video if you did enjoy comment if
you guys agree with anything that I said
in this or if there needs to be changed
or something something's going on that I
didn't know about that be greatly
appreciated in a i'll see you guys next
time with peace out